my name is mark morgan from clarksville
johnson county
we're here at peach picking paradise
we grow peaches about
25 varieties
spread out uh
over
about seven weeks or so of harvest and
uh today we're going to be answering
some questions about peach production in
arkansas
okay so the first question is uh you
know there used to be a lot more peach
orchards in arkansas uh maybe how come
there there aren't as many uh around
today you know there used to be a lot
more peach orchards around i remember
even just growing up there there was
more orchards in the state
i think it's a combination of things
you know
it's a very difficult crop to rely on
cash flow there's good years and bad
years and it's it's very difficult from
a financial standpoint to keep that even
the other thing is labor we still do so
much with peaches as far as hand
harvesting hand proving uh you know
thinning it's a lot of shoulders and
elbows
as far as you know the mechanicalization
as you know tractors things like that
they have in the row crop side
we haven't got as much of that in our
industry and so it's uh you know finding
labor at the right times is uh is
definitely a challenge
all right the next question uh
how long uh will a peach tree bear fruit
uh you know
if you're going if you're planting in
the ground that hadn't had peaches on it
you know you really should be able to
get 20 years maybe even or more
out of that tree as far as us we've been
in commercial production kind of on the
same soils for a while we're we're
really shooting more for that 15
uh just because uh it's had so many
peaches on it in the past but uh you
know really 20 years or longer you know
if you take care of it it'll it takes
about that third year uh to to really
start producing them but uh but yeah 20
15 20 years in arkansas
[Applause]
all right our uh
our next question was kind of uh
you know as far as uh peach what the
what the calendar looks like what we're
doing uh certain times a year uh we
usually start we're in bloom now
obviously uh but we usually start uh in
january doing pruning we prune january
february
hope to be done before bloom we've got a
little bit left here
but that's really whenever we're coming
in and pruning
if we're lucky enough to have a you know
this is the time of year we start really
looking for freezes we want to avoid
those to have a crop you know april may
june sometimes you can have two full of
a crop where a peach will put on way too
many peaches that it could stand so we
have to come in and thin that
then there'll be harvest season uh of
course irrigation you know uh mowing
around the trees keeping the weeds down
stuff like that and then in the fall
after we're done harvesting we come in
uh do some uh do some work to to really
get ready for the next year's crop as
far as uh you know looking for peach
tree borers spraying uh
and and really uh helping that tree have
the best setup it can be for the next
year
so when is the peak peach season in
arkansas uh you know in arkansas we can
grow peaches june july august uh really
even september to october
most uh mostly for us it's july you know
we start uh
mid-june and really go through august
but uh july you know we try to be going
by july 4th
we've got the peach festival in johnson
county the third week of july july is
really whenever we get going
here in clarksville
all right the next question is uh
what it uh why do peaches have fuzz or
what is the uh the peach fuzz on the
peach uh
the the fuzz really is a a defense
mechanism you know it keeps uh certain
insects uh from either you know
traveling over the fruit or laying eggs
on it so it's really uh it's a helpful
thing to in in defense of some insects
we uh you know if you look at the some
of the newer varieties the old-timers
used to talk about all the fuzz you know
being in the air and the packing shed
and
i think the newer varieties have a
little bit less fuzz on them than they
used to uh you know there's also the
nectarine and nectarine uh is a peach
you know pretty much it
on the inside it is it just does not
have fuzz on the outside
it has a recessive gene that doesn't
doesn't put on fuzz so
[Applause]
all right
our next question uh the difference
between uh freestone peaches and cling
peaches uh so on a peach
you know it's gonna have the stone or
the seed in the middle you know a
freestone would just break right off the
off the seed the the first freestone
really developed commercially with the
alberta
since then they've developed tons of
free stones
a lot of people prefer the freestones
but we also you know the cling you can't
just break it apart it's going to stick
to the seed but a lot of the cling
varieties we grow have a pretty big
following and that people would come you
know just specifically to get that cling
uh you know if you're just cooking with
it or whatever the free stone may be a
little bit easier uh but if you know
what you're doing with the cling and uh
really uh are used to that you know more
traditional taste
it has a big following as well
the next question
is uh can i plant a peach pit and grow
my own tree
uh yeah you can't you can grow a tree
from a pit the issue is is uh all of our
uh peach trees are grafted so you know
they have a root stock and then the
variety grafted onto it so it's kind of
a hybrid tree so the the seed you plant
you're not going to get exactly you know
what kind of peach it came from there's
going to be a little bit of variance
there but yeah it will grow a tree you
can you can get a peach tree from a pit
so do animals like deer and squirrel
like to eat peaches yes
yes and no
we all you know we have to have a deer
fence uh we've got so much deer pressure
that uh the deer don't necessarily eat
the peaches as much as where they really
hurt us as they eat the leaves
especially on younger trees they can
come through and just you know eat all
the leaves and then all of a sudden you
don't have any leaves the tree's dead
squirrels that they're gonna you know
you'll see squirrels going out and
taking ripe peaches out all the time uh
you know our our theory on that you just
got to grow more than they can carry out
they're going to get their share
got another question about like how do
you keep insects off
your peaches well it depends on the time
of year you know this time of year we're
in bloom
we don't want any insecticides or
anything we've got our bees working
now later in the year whenever you start
getting closer to harvest
we have to keep a pretty routine spray
schedule to keep
keep insects off of the fruit
you know your local county extension
agent uh can provide all kinds of uh
spray programs and things like that uh
it's uh you know something that you kind
of need to stay on top of but you also
you need to do scouting to go out uh to
see what your issues are because
sometimes you may go out and you may not
have any issues sometimes you may start
uh you know seeing the development of
something that could turn into a bigger
issue so you know scouting and uh and
contacting your county extension agent
would be uh my recommendation all right
and the final question uh why don't
people say uh that they're feeling
peachy when they're feeling happy uh you
know i really don't know that's uh
you've always heard that or peachy keen
or all that stuff
you know i just know that uh you know
when it's harvest season and and we've
got fresh fruit uh out here and it's you
know it's from an arkansas peach orchard
uh and they can taste it you know i
think to me that's what feeling peachy
is you know it's just that fresh uh you
know hadn't been processed it's just
right there and fresh and that's sure
hard to beat
and so uh we're looking forward to
having a good uh good crop this year so
far so good hopefully it'll stay with us
and uh you know go uh go eat some local
arkansas peaches this year at your local
peach orchard
uh
[Music]